ايش اسمك ميرا من دار مين ابو زينب ايش
مالك احبان طيب بابا بقول فيش دواء ما
اخذتي دواء زمان انا خايفه اموت لا يا عمو
ان شاء الله ما بتموتي ما فيش ميه ما فيش
اكل الميه اللي عننا كلها مالحه نعم وهيات
الاكل اللي كله عننا قليل الدواش العياده
كانت مفتوحه وسكرت وبطلت تفتح مريضه اخذه
كبد وبائي اخذت الفيروس هذا من المدرسه
الدكاتره قالو لي هي بنتك علاجها السكريات
والميه الحلوه طبعا لا في سكريات ولا في
مي حلوه تعبانه ما في طول الوقت نايمه
اغلب الوقت مقضيها نوم لا ميه ولا اكل ولا
شرب وهذ عندها مات حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
على العرب اللي ساكتين وسايبنا هول اذا
ماتوا لمين اروح اناعم لمين روحنا الحقونا
احنا قاعدين بنموت يعني انا بنتي بلا
مؤخذه اليوم صابها المرض بكره حصيب اطفال
ثاني هذا في عدو بعدي يعني بكره حصير
هيتنا مرض كبد وبائي اذا متنا من الاحتلال
حموت من
المرض